DR. JOHANNES FREIESLEBEN:
Ladies and gentleman,
70% of all employees
are unhappy at work.
70%.
This is at least if
we trust in Gallup.
Gallup came up with this study.
It's an ongoing, daily
job engagement study
that they conducted since 2000.
And they found that around
30% of all employees
are the employees that
companies really love.
They are engaged, they're
happy in what they do,
they are passionate about what
they do, they're productive,
but 50% are not engaged.
Are not engaged.
They're sleepwalking,
they're not doing much.
They're not doing harm
either, but 20% do.
20% are actively disengaged.
This is a study for the US.
It's on a daily basis.
90,000 employees participate,
roughly, on a daily basis.
Well, one thing I
learned at university
is that you never
trust only one study.
So there are several studies out
there on unhappiness at work,
and you end up with
very different results
depending on the study
design, on the participants,
and on the scaling, and
the definitions you use.
So the range is big.
Some studies for
Germany-- recent studies--
say 49% are unhappy.
And a big international
consultancy
came even up with 90%,
which I personally think
has a hidden agenda behind it.
Most likely they want to sell
some improvement programs,
but it is a large number.
It is a large number.
And the question is why is that.
Why do we have so much
unhappiness at work?
I take questions after the talk.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DR. JOHANNES FREIESLEBEN: OK.
OK.
Good.
It is a very sorry
state as well,
if you think about it, because
happiness is maybe the biggest
gift mother nature gave to
us, in terms of feelings
that we can experience.
It's a very beautiful
feeling, sensually beautiful.
And it connects us with
a lot of philosophers,
religious thinkers,
even statesmen.
I mean, all of you know that
the founding fathers of the US,
they put it even in the
Declaration of Independence,
that the strive for
happiness is essentially
a self-evident pursuit
of the human being.
And I think self-evident
it is, because we all
strive for happiness.
Every single day.
Most of us even say
this is a life goal.
We want to be happy at the end.
So as a scientist,
you are confronted
with many, many concepts.
Right?
And what I love to do is
try to put some numbers
behind concepts, because
sometimes these concepts they
just sound great, but you want
to see what's the impact of it.
So let's make a little
hypothetical calculation.
We are all in Switzerland.
We have 8.3 million
inhabitants in Switzerland,
out of whom about four
million are employees.
And let's assume that
since Switzerland
is a beautiful country-- you
have beautiful mountains,
lots of chocolate around-- that
only 30% are unhappy at work.
Only 30%.
Not 70, not 50, only 30.
That makes 1.2 million.
Let us assume for the
ease of calculation
that we could magically lift
up their happiness by 10%.
So let's say 10% of the
work time gets more happy.
On the basis of about
2000 hours per year--
that's 200 hours per person--
that's 240 million more happy
work hours.
That is a lot.
And I will show you
in a minute there
is a direct correlation between
happiness and productivity.
So if you think about, 240
million more productive
work hours per year, that has
a big impact on the society.
And you can do the calculation
for all of the countries
that we have participants from.
The American scholar and
poet William Lloyd Phelps
said, about 70 years
ago, the happiest people
are those who think the
most interesting thoughts.
And I think he is right.
I think he is totally right.
And interesting thoughts are
the drivers of all progress.
For us and for all societies.
So why have so many
people unhappy?
What a waste.
Isn't it?
What I want to discuss with
you in the next 60 minutes
is ways of getting out
of this situation, ways
of improving happiness at work.
And I will present you
a little bit of theory,
but then I want to present to
you a model that we developed.
A structural model of
how to organize a company
to make people more happy.
But first of all, happiness
is such an essential concept
that you have a lot of
different perceptions about it,
so let's define it first.
It's important to
distinguish it from pleasure.
Pleasure is a
momentary satisfaction.
Ice cream on a hot day, you
consume it, you are happy.
When it's done, it's done,
you're not happy anymore.
Happiness has two main
aspects, and one is hedonic
and the other is eudaimonic.
Hedonic happiness is
the external happiness.
That is all the external
events that make you happy.
For instance, your boss
gives you a thumbs up.
Or you move to a
beautiful, new office.
You're happy, you enjoy
it, it's a pleasant state.
Eudaimonic is more the inner
happiness, more profound.
It's a deep dimension
of happiness.
So everything that
comes out of yourself.
The value systems that you have,
the motivation that you feel,
the fulfillment of
your human potential.
And also doing what is
virtuous in your perspective.
This is a very
profound happiness
that doesn't need to show
in momentary happiness.
It is the basis of your
personal happiness.
Well, actually, I found a pretty
good definition of happiness
on Wikipedia.
"Happiness is a mental or
emotional state of well-being,
defined by positive
or pleasant emotions
ranging from contentment
to intense joy."
What is important to say
here is that happiness
doesn't have to be 100%.
Happy people usually also
have unhappy moments.
They're not happy all the time.
Researchers say about 80% of
the time, when you are mostly
happy, you're a happy person.
So 20% of your time
you can be unhappy.
Also it has no relation
to the intensity.
You don't need to be
euphoric all the time.
Mildly to moderately
happy 80% of your time,
then you are a happy person.
I will show you now that
happiness is pretty modifiable,
because if you look at
those four contributors
there, the drivers that cause
happiness in human beings.
You have environmental
contributors,
we briefly spoke about it.
The ice cream, the nice boss.
Also factors like being
married, having a high income,
having a great job.
All of those things
make people happy.
However, the effect
is very, very small.
Once basic needs are
fulfilled-- the Maslow pyramid--
those external factors
account for about 8% to 15%
of variation in happiness.
So not a lot.
Individual contributors
account for more.
We talk about personal traits
and genetic set points.
Genetics set points is a
very interesting theory that
actually came up
when researchers
looked at the happiness
of lottery winners.
And they found that
if you win a lottery
you have a big
spike in happiness,
but it doesn't last long.
It usually lasts between
three and four weeks.
And then, funnily
enough, your happiness
comes back to the
level before you won.
Just pretty quickly.
So there is some genetic set up
that all of us have, you know.
Some are inclined to be
more happy, others not.
And personality traits
are those things
that you acquire
during your childhood
from your family background.
For instance,
healthy self-esteem
or a natural optimism.
Interaction
contributors basically
means a fit between yourself
and your expectations,
and the situation you encounter.
I'll give you an
example for that.
If you have to go to
a client on Monday
and you expect a Volkswagen
Golf company car,
you might be very happy
because [INAUDIBLE]
that you receive a Golf or
maybe even a better car.
If you expect a Lamborghini,
you might be very disappointed,
and might be unhappy as
a result. So, basically,
expectations you have
regarding certain situations.
And then, lastly,
behavioral contributors.
You can actually
acquire behaviors
that make you more happy.
For instance, coming out
of positive psychology,
using your strengths at work.
You are good-- all of you
are good in something.
If you can apply those strengths
and talents in your daily work
routines, you're going
to be more happy.
If you cannot apply them,
most likely unhappy.
Also you can adopt some advice
from eastern philosophy.
So pursuing intrinsic goals
instead of extrinsic goals.
Relationships instead
of money or fame.
Being mindful and
aware, knowing what's
going on around
you in the world,
and involved in a purpose
larger than yourself.
If you look at all
these for drivers,
only the genetics part is
non-modifiable, the rest is.
OK.
So happiness actually
can be influenced.
There has been a very
interesting change
in the academic
community regarding
happiness in the past 10 years.
There's always been
the clear correlation
between happiness and
successful life outcomes,
how we call them.
Like wealth, fame, great jobs,
marriage, being attractive,
and so on and so forth.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DR. JOHANNES FREIESLEBEN:
Let me explain.
Usually, the researchers thought
you have to be successful first
and that makes you happy.
Right?
You have to be married
and then you become happy.
Or you earn a lot of money
and that makes you happy.
Well, since about
10 years this view
has changed completely
to the opposite.
They say, well, you
have to be happy first,
and then you're going
to be successful.
Then you're going to have all
those desirable life outcomes.
It has been supported by a
huge study done on, basically,
all the empirical material
which was out there.
All cross-sectional,
longitudinal, experimental
studies.
And I think about 1,000 they
revised, and looked especially
at this causality and
found that's the way.
First you are happy,
then you're successful.
Of course, there's a little
reinforcing feedback loop,
but the main causality goes
from happiness to success.
So it's worthwhile to be happy.
Right?
It's worthwhile not only for
you, but also for the company.
And this is most likely what
all managers like to look at.
If you have happy
employees you have
employees which are proactive,
creative, innovative,
motivated, and so on.
Have low job withdrawal and
contribute to the organization
in many different ways.
Some researchers call that
organizational spontaneity.
That means you help others.
You become an ambassador for
your company out in real life.
And you are making a lot of
constructive suggestions.
So all of these points, all
of these direct results,
have been empirically validated.
And the indirect results even
more interesting for a company.
Superior performance.
Of course, if people are happy
and they are more productive
and they are more
committed, you are
going to see it in financial
results at the end of the day.
And this has also been
verified by empirical studies.
They found a very strong
correlation between happiness
of employees and broad
performance measures of 0.50,
which is a very high
value for a correlation.
Employee retention as well.
Any company is interested
in keeping the good people
and if you have a lot of
happy people, meaning you
must do something right.
You give them good
career options,
you give them space to develop.
And so the tenure of
happy people in companies
tend to be longer than
for unhappy people.
Also not very surprising result.
So we can say happiness
at work does matter.
It's not a topic that
has no relevance.
It does matter.
I quickly want to
show you the four
levels on which an organization
can influence happiness.
That's the job level, the
leader level, the team level,
and the organizational
level itself.
And the job level had
received most attention
in the literature.
I would guess
between 80% and 90%.
There have been hundreds
if not thousands of studies
about job satisfaction, job
engagement, job enlargement,
job enrichment.
All of these
task-oriented concepts.
They're going to modify
your job and then
you want to be
happy-- hopefully.
Lately, there has
been a shift here,
as well, to a
strength-based approach,
also rooted in
positive psychology.
Where you look more at
the design of the job
according to the strength
of the individual employee.
So we have a shift from a purely
task-oriented concept to a more
people-oriented concept.
The same holds true in
leadership theories.
Interestingly enough, there
is very little on leadership
and happiness.
Very, very little.
Don't ask me why.
I don't know.
You know, it influences the
happiness of his employees,
but there's very little
research about it.
Very little empirical studies.
Well, leader roles also changed.
About 20 years
back, 25 years back,
you had still the Tayloristic
or Fayol model of leadership.
Meaning, a leader plans,
organizes, controls.
Very functional.
And these days leader roles
also include, or shift more to,
motivating your employees,
coaching them, mentoring them,
developing them,
also their strength.
And monitoring them,
instead of controlling,
which is a fundamentally
different concept.
So, again, we see a shift from
a functional task-oriented
leadership perception to a
more people-centered leadership
perception.
The team.
Well, I guess most
of you could agree
that team members
have a large influence
on your individual happiness.
At least, I can relate to
this from my experience.
Again, very little
research on this.
Funnily.
But it is obvious that if you
work in a team where everybody
takes different to you,
makes you uncomfortable,
makes you unhappy.
I worked in a big bank
before and most bankers
are very extrinsically
motivated.
So bonus, money, revenue.
And if you are a soul
searcher-- if you
want to find meaning
in business--
that's the wrong place for you.
You're going to be unhappy.
I was unhappy.
The fourth level is
the organization.
And, again, here
a lot of research
has contributed to
the question, how
can we make people more happy
on an organizational level.
What did they find?
Culture.
Organizational culture.
And I agree that if you have
a great culture-- if you have
a great value system
in your company,
if you have a clear mission,
vision, and all of this,
if you have clear
guidelines for management
how to deal with employees
in certain situations-- yes,
you will make people more happy.
But the problem is
it rarely works.
Why?
Very simple.
Because you have to have
100% commitment of everybody.
If you have only
one leader who says,
yeah, you know, I
don't think it works.
It will not work.
His team-- he will treat
his team as always.
They get frustrated.
They say, oh, well, look we have
this culture of mutual respect
and fairness and we
cherish opinions,
but I cannot approach my leader
and tell him my new ideas.
There's a disconnect.
They get even frustrated.
There are very little
organization cultures,
that I know, that really work.
It is important to note
that happiness is not
created on those levels.
It's created in
here, in the brains
of every single individual.
In his perceptions
and interpretations
of what's happening there.
So this is a very
individualistic notion.
And there are many scholars
that actually say, well,
because individuals differ
so much in their needs,
in their wants, their
perceptions, interpretations,
their attitudes-- there is no
single solution to happiness.
And there are other scholars
that even go one step further.
They say, you know, why
should companies, at all,
get involved in this
happiness business.
There is no single
solution that fits all.
Would you agree with that?
No.
Good.
I wanted to hear that.
I don't agree with that either.
I do not agree with that.
What you see, if you look at
the literature on those four
levels, is a very
interesting thing.
A very interesting observation.
There are no structural
approaches to happiness.
What do I mean with
structural approaches?
Companies are organized in a
certain way we call structure.
And these ways have not
changed since about 200 years.
And I ask myself, why?
Why can't we find a structure
that promotes happiness?
There's nothing out there.
Why are organizations so rigid?
You come into an organization
as a new employee,
your boss is given, your team
is given, everything is given.
It's very rigid.
And this is why I want to do
a little excursion with you
into the traditional way
of structuring companies.
Which is this.
You have an overall task.
Producing a service,
producing a product.
You split this into subtasks
and you bundle or cluster
those subtasks
into certain jobs.
Now, you are doing all the
IT work and [INAUDIBLE]
doing all the sales process.
I'm doing all the talking.
And then you put those jobs
into a hierarchical structure.
That's called
departmentalization.
Difficult word.
Well, this is going on
according to function, which
is the most common approach.
So marketing people
marketing department,
IT people IT
department, and so on.
Or regional structures-- team
Switzerland, team Germany,
team Austria.
Or project-based-- I
think you at Google
have a project-based
organization.
Or you have metrics, which is
a hybrid structure with two
reporting lines.
And they never work.
I'm not a big fan of those.
They never work.
But nothing about happiness
enters the picture here.
Nothing.
It's just purely task-oriented.
You have this task to
fulfill, there you go.
So I put up this as
a problem statement.
Why don't we shift to a
flexible structure reflecting
different happiness
profiles of people?
Why don't we do that?
If we can structure jobs
according to strengths,
why can't we structure companies
according to happiness?
We need, basically,
an organizational form
that reflects the differences
in employee's happiness.
And we are all different.
That is true.
We are all different in
regards to happiness.
But so one thing a
solution doesn't fit,
but maybe that does.
Let me present it to you.
As they say, you can choose your
friends, but not your family.
And you can choose your job, but
not the people you work with.
Thus, many of us,
spend eight hours a day
working alongside,
or even reporting to,
the last people we would pick.
And, I think, this is
very true in many cases.
So let's see what
we can do about it.
We developed a model that I
called organizational happiness
model.
And I just didn't find
a better word for it,
but maybe I will in the future.
And to come up with a structure
you have to keep process.
The first is happiness profiling
of every single employee--
existing and incoming-- to look
at personality type, abilities,
interests, talents, business
needs, personal needs,
attitudes, professional
values, ethical values,
preferred leadership
style, personal vision,
and motivators.
You have all
different categories
that code for happiness
in the work life.
Preferred leadership style,
for instance, just to pick one.
I guess many of you love
management by objectives.
Your boss gives
you some objective,
and you run after it.
Independently.
I love that.
But not everybody
loves it like this.
There are people that
love to be micromanaged,
that want to have a clear tasks
that they can repeat every day,
and want to see the boss
10 times a day to check.
That's valid too.
Not everybody's the same.
So once we've done the happiness
profile of the employee,
we're going to allocate
him to the team
leader with the closest
possible happiness profile.
And these clusters--
we call them
happiness clusters-- form the
new teams of the organization.
It's not a marketing team,
it's not a original team,
it's not a project team,
it is a happiness team.
OK.
Just a brief word on
the happiness clusters.
The mix of the team
can be adjusted.
That's nothing fixed
in that structure.
Members have to be similar.
You might have experienced
that from your own personal
background in companies
from your own experience,
that you get along well with
people that tic in the same way
as you do.
That have the same wave length.
OK.
Is that true?
Can you relate to that?
Are most similar in attitudes,
in beliefs, in values,
not so much in
talents and abilities.
There's a lot of theory
on complementary teams.
Winning teams, you have to
have different abilities
in one team.
Yes, granted.
But you can do that
with this system.
You have similar people
that differ in capabilities.
So the [INAUDIBLE] is
to structure a company
as clusters of
happiness profiles,
instead of clusters
of functions.
Now, how could this look like?
It gets a little complex.
The normal structure you
have seen is the big pyramid.
This is a sort of a
pyramid too, but it works
according to different rules.
Let's start at the top.
The CEO is still the CEO.
So not a big change here.
Then you have the C-level,
the management board-- chief
operating officer, chief
information officer, and so on
and so forth-- same roles.
They are still there.
You have a new roll called
chief happiness officer,
and this guy is responsible
for all happiness
leaders, [INAUDIBLE] L,
and all happiness clusters.
So he is responsible,
basically, for all employees.
The normal C-level managers
have no direct reports anymore.
That's a new thing.
The roads are similar
but a little different
than in a normal
hierarchical organization.
So the C-level managers,
they are still specialists,
they still craft the
strategy of the company.
So we want to go there.
We are going to launch
this new product.
But they don't directly
communicate anymore
with the employees.
This is done via
the chief happiness
officer and the happiness
leaders of the single teams.
Why is that?
Because they have the role, or
the task, to make the two parts
fit-- the different
happiness profiles
of their employees
and the goals.
So the work is shaped
regarding the humans
and not the humans are
shaped regarding work.
That's the big topic here.
The employees.
If you're an employee
and you are allocated
to the first cluster,
because you like the boss,
he likes you, he knows your
strength, he supports you,
he coaches you, he
guides you, great.
You have your happiness cluster.
That's your team.
But you might work on very
different project teams.
So it is sort of a project
organization that you
know of here, of Google.
You work in different
project teams
and you might work with
different employees
from different clusters.
No problem.
You do that now.
Right?
Different departments,
different teams.
What's the big difference?
It is quite complicated.
Isn't it?
What is complicated here?
The talking.
These people need to talk a lot.
In a normal hierarchical
organization
you have top-down information.
You have push information.
The C-level manager
says, I want to do this.
And then he goes to
his department bosses
and they break it
up in little goals
and then they break it
down to the employee level.
So Information
pushed from the top.
Here that doesn't work,
because the C-level has to talk
with the happiness leaders.
They have to coordinate.
They have to make things fit.
It's more of a collaboration
and negotiation
than a hierarchical command
and control structure.
A little word on the
happiness leaders.
They are the new team heads.
Right?
They are the new
department heads.
They are the former
managers, but they are not
functional managers anymore.
They might know nothing
about what you do-- actually,
they should know a little
bit, because they still
have to monitor your goal
progress, and stuff like this.
They have to talk with
you about your projects.
They have to have a general
understanding on all
of the functions in
the company, but they
don't have to be a functional
specialist anymore.
OK.
Their main role
is to mentor you,
to coach you, according
to your happiness profile.
To give you the best
environmental conditions
to be productive and to be
happy, to use your strengths.
And I give you a
very simple example.
Some of you might be
fathers and mothers.
So you might have
little children
that you want to see in the
morning before going to work.
In most companies bosses say,
you have to be here at 7:30.
Work starts at 7:30.
There's no other way.
In this structure, if you are
allocated to this happiness
team where being late at
work is totally fine and OK,
because everybody thinks
like this-- your boss
and your teammates--
there will be no problem.
The only problem
is the team head
has to speak with the
C-level managers and the rest
of the company to
make that work.
It's a lot of
cooperation going on,
a lot of negotiation
in this system.
So this is the new idea.
Let's assess it.
Let's see where
are the strengths
and where are the challenges.
Well, the strengths are,
in my view, obvious.
You want to lift up the
happiness of your employees,
because you allocate
them to the cluster
where they could
potentially perform best.
Where they have the
ideal conditions,
the best fit of
happiness and work.
And, as a result, you have a
better company performance.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DR. JOHANNES FREIESLEBEN: Can
we do a questions afterwards?
Theoretically, this model
works in all organizations
and in all cultural backgrounds.
In all.
I don't see where
it couldn't work,
because it's very flexible.
If you, for instance, have
to integrate a company
from the Arabic Peninsula
and people culturally
different there--
that's no problem,
they'll form their cluster.
Or they are allocated to the
clusters that fit them best.
It promotes company wide
collaboration into action.
It has to, it needs to.
It only functions if
there is a lot of talking.
And it is a very
flexible structure
that can easily be modified.
You, as an employee, you can
also change happiness clusters,
if you somehow feel that
it doesn't work anymore
in this happiness cluster.
You go to the one
that suits you best.
What about the challenges?
Well, it's a redesign
of the whole company.
You're talking
about restructuring.
Talk about adjusting processes,
workflows, information flows,
and the like.
It's a big task.
However, there might be
big benefits, as well.
If you do it.
It might demand a
culture change, as well.
If you have a pretty happiness
oriented culture already,
difference is not so big.
So that might work quite nicely.
If you come from a very
hierarchical organized company,
you might have bigger
challenges there.
You have new roles for managers.
That's for sure.
Not all managers might
be happy with that.
For instance, if I would be
a COO, and all of a sudden I
don't have any direct
reports anymore,
I might say, well,
this is a power loss.
In this system-- actually,
in this new structure
is not the classical
power we know
from hierarchical companies.
It is more influencing.
It is more negotiating.
So managers need to understand
your roles in this model.
You need to understand that
power works in different ways.
It requires very,
very good persons
to be the happiness leaders
of those happiness clusters.
It's a very, very
demanding and complex task.
And the most important shift is
from the hierarchical control
to collaboration
and self-management.
So the teams-- the
project teams--
are naturally self-managing.
Is it very different
from what we see today?
Yes it is.
It is new.
No company runs on
this model so far.
But we have aspects of
it in many companies.
Self-managing teams
are everywhere.
Managing by objective
is everywhere.
Right.
Making people
happier-- this idea
is in most companies these days.
They didn't go the final step,
which was such a structure.
So far.
So I want to conclude
my talk-- and then
we can open the discussion--
with the prerequisites.
When does that organizational
happiness model
work and is effective?
Well, clearly, it has to
turn in a net benefit.
Otherwise companies won't do it.
It has to show end results.
So, the increase
in productivity due
to organizational happiness,
due to allocating persons there
where they have
the best fit, must
be bigger than the productivity
loss that you have,
because you have
to coordinate more.
I believe at the beginning, yes.
You will have a lot of
effort to make this work
in terms of coordination.
But this will
diminish after time.
And, I'd say, after
two to three years it
will be the same effort
you spend in any company.
Because also, in normal
functional companies
the departments need to
talk with each other.
There is collaboration
going on all the time.
It requires a certain
employee attitude as well.
You cannot do that
with everybody.
So what you do--
the proposition is
you create a framework of
those happiness clusters
where individual
people can perform,
but they have to
be able to perform
and they have to
want to perform.
It's not a given.
If you think about those 20%
actively disengaged people
the Gallup found,
maybe they will not
use the leeway in the new
beautiful structure to perform.
Maybe they don't use
their skills to flourish.
It's up to the individual.
And then you need a
humanistic company culture.
Companies must be very
committed to this.
And they must have some sort
of humanistic viewpoint.
And humanistic management,
basically, centers on the idea
that every person
is an end in itself.
And that you can align business
goals with the humanistic goals
and societal goals.
They can be aligned.
They're not contradictory.
So it puts the human
being back into the center
of the equation.
And this is exactly what
organizational happiness does.
Exactly that.
Regard the human being, when
is that human being most happy,
when does it perform best.
And we structure the
company according to that.
And we put the human back
in the center of interest
because all companies
that are out there
are not in the b2b business--
in the business to business
business.
They're not in
the b2c business--
business to consumer.
They are in the h2h
business-- human to human.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
Very good question.
Thank you.
Your question was,
you have certain types
of people that need control that
are extrinsically motivated.
How do you integrate
them into this structure?
The short answer is, it's in the
hands of the happiness leader.
So you're allocated, regarding
your happiness profile,
to a certain happiness cluster.
To a happiness team led
by this happiness leader.
And he has to really
understand you,
he has to know how you tic.
He has to know all your strength
and-- well-- weakness also.
Maybe by experience-- you
will reveal them in a test.
But He will know
you pretty well.
And he has to design your
work according to your needs.
According to the best fit of
your abilities and the work.
If you take
extrinsically-- which
is totally fine-- you
might end up in a team--
we have all team mates
that tic extrinsically.
So for instance, any
chief financial manager
will likely have a
lot of finance teams
with finance guys.
And they tend to
tic extrinsically.
They love money, they
want to make money,
and that's totally fine.
There's nothing against it.
It's their motivator.
AUDIENCE: I'm in legal.
There's many people [INAUDIBLE].
DR. JOHANNES FREIESLEBEN:
Oh, OK. [INAUDIBLE]
But you know what the good
thing about this structure is?
You are now on the legal
team and you might not
be extrinsically motivated.
You might be
intrinsically motivated.
In this structure you've
got to be in a team that
is intrinsically motivated.
So your boss is intrinsically
motivated and your teammates.
You will collaborate
with the other legal guys
on a project basis, but formally
you will be intrinsic class.
Understand [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Ah, so you
change, basically, the role?
DR. JOHANNES FREIESLEBEN:
You change the role.
Precisely.
AUDIENCE: What does
team mean to you
if projects are done by
people in different things?
Like, for me an optional
project and a team
they go together as one thing.
Of course there are
[INAUDIBLE] projects,
like you do back-end algorithms
and then [INAUDIBLE].
For me it is not like
project and team.
[INAUDIBLE]
DR. JOHANNES FREIESLEBEN: Yes.
So the question is-- for you
the notions of project and team
goes together.
Right?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DR. JOHANNES
FREIESLEBEN: Well, that
means you work on
different teams then.
You work on different projects
you work on different teams.
Correct.
AUDIENCE: I think it's more
if you work in one team
and you collaborate
with other teams
to accomplish
[INAUDIBLE] projects.
And then you have some
projects that you don't
need to collaborate with them.
DR. JOHANNES FREIESLEBEN:
Well, you work in one team
and then you collaborate
with other project leaders?
Well, this is exactly you.
That's exactly you.
You are going to be
in one happiness team,
but your work will be
in different teams.
Might be with your team mates
from here, but might not.
Right?
Could be completely
different team.
It's a very flexible structure.
You understand?
You can be-- depending
on your task,
on your project-- you can be
in x teams at the same time.
But physically and
management wise here,
in one happiness cluster.
Did I explain myself?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
DR. JOHANNES FREIESLEBEN: OK.
Next question.
AUDIENCE: Actually I want to
elaborate on this question.
I mean, this is really a
very interesting vision.
And I simply [INAUDIBLE]
formulation of society
where a sense of [INAUDIBLE]
is relating happiness and not
money.
[INAUDIBLE]
But if you look at this
model as you presented,
there is something
which occurred to me.
So say I am motivated,
I don't know,
by making tea and [INAUDIBLE].
And I will put this in the
happiness questionnaire.
And I'm assigned to a
team where other people
like the same things and we
think the same as you say.
Now say I'm a software
engineer and there would
be a [INAUDIBLE] person there.
And there would be
[INAUDIBLE] stuff, and maybe
someone from the [INAUDIBLE].
And OK, we are all on
the same happiness team.
We have the same manager.
Maybe we sit in the same place.
Maybe we have lunch together.
But otherwise we [INAUDIBLE].
So we [INAUDIBLE].
When I work with other
people on that project,
[INAUDIBLE] like coffee.
DR. JOHANNES FREIESLEBEN: That
is a very, very good question.
The question was, well you want
to be in a happiness cluster.
But most of your work
is in the project teams.
[INAUDIBLE]
So how does the happiness
culture affect you?
It affects you via three ways.
First is, if you have
team events on your site,
you go to lunch together,
if you have team events,
if you are working on your
own, you sit in a team
where the people
are the same ways.
Let's call you friends, right?
The second thing is
your leader assesses
you regarding your happiness.
He has a very complicated role.
And maybe I have to explain
that a little better.
He has to make sure that
the company goals are
fulfilled, the project
goals, at the same time
your happiness profile.
You understand?
This is a very demanding role.
That is why he has
to speak with the CHO
and the other C-level
managers that might have
an interest in the audience.
[INAUDIBLE]
They have to find the
best fit between the two.
And I give you--
you're totally right.
It has big implications for
companies because it's not only
profit that they're
after, but also happiness.
As humanistic
management proclaims,
business goals align
with humanistic goals.
They both have the same value,
otherwise it doesn't work.
If your company
doesn't understand
it, if they say we just
want to make bucks, come on,
it wouldn't fly.
It would not work.
Maybe this other company
you want to work for.
AUDIENCE: I have
another question.
So imagine as the CHO and he
has a lot of happiness meters.
All those [INAUDIBLE].
So what kind of [INAUDIBLE] is
used, framework or whatever,
in order to classify
these people?
A poet uses spoken words,
but what kind of words?
So is there any notion of
what kind of dimensions
these people want to
kind of [INAUDIBLE]?
DR. JOHANNES FREIESLEBEN:
I have to be honest, no,
not at the moment.
This is a very new concept here,
[INAUDIBLE] end of last year.
And it's not thought
through on the detail role.
The role of the CHO though
is to provide a framework
where this happiness
index can work best.
So he has to basically make
the whole organization work.
He has took to make
sure that if there
are goal conflicts for
instance, which might happen
all the time between C-level
and happiness [INAUDIBLE],
he has to mediate.
He has to somehow
find a compromise.
It's a very demanding role.
He has also to lead the
negotiation because you
have those two dimensions.
As your colleagues
said correctly,
you have business dimension and
you have happiness dimension.
They have to go hand in hand.
They need to be a fit.
That's his role.
What kind of language he uses,
what kind of systems he uses,
we're not there yet.
But it's about [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: I have some
questions about how
it's on the role [INAUDIBLE].
So let's say for example a
company with 50,000 employees,
and you have 20 employees
per happiness cluster,
That means you have
2,500 [INAUDIBLE].
So the CHOs, they
shoot [INAUDIBLE].
And the CHO should solve all
the conflicts between all
these things, [INAUDIBLE].
That seems to me to be a
task that would take more
than [INAUDIBLE] time.
DR. JOHANNES FREIESLEBEN:
I would agree.
So the question was, if you have
a big company of 50,000 people
and you have 20 people
per happiness cluster,
you might end up with
2,500 different happiness
clusters that will be a
coordination and communication
disaster.
That's impossible.
Correct.
But I don't think
it would go there.
I think it will
go there that you
might have, not depending upon
the company's size, about 10
to a maximum of 15 different
types of happiness clusters.
There might be a hundred
happiness clusters at one time.
[INAUDIBLE] the same procedures
and the same processes,
the same information.
Do you understand me?
So you don't have
to manage 2,500.
That would be impossible.
You have to manage
a subset of them,
let's say 500, 300 of one
time-- the same rules,
the same procedures.
So that's doable.
2,500 is not doable.
So I agree.
I think [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: So I think it is a
continuation of the questions
that we'll have before.
In traditional
companies, the teams
are usually structured around
like you said department.
But what you spend most
of your time doing, right,
if you support [INAUDIBLE].
Like if you sit
with the lawyers,
you're in the legal department.
If you sit, that's a
departmental company.
And then here at Google, if
you sit with this [INAUDIBLE]
from the teamwork
based on this project.
But in your example, even though
I'm in some happiness cluster,
I don't actually spend
most of the time.
DR. JOHANNES FREIESLEBEN:
No, that's correct.
It depends.
So the question, if
I can reframe you,
is how much time do you actually
spend on your happiness team.
Is that the base
of your question?
AUDIENCE: Right, yeah.
Just because part of the
parameters of your talk
was that we spend most of the
time during the day with people
we don't like.
So hopefully with this change,
we can spend most of the time
with people that are
having [INAUDIBLE].
DR. JOHANNES FREIESLEBEN:
You might have misunderstood
me a just a little bit.
I didn't say you spent most
of the time with people
that you don't like.
It might be that you
spend all of your time
with people you don't like.
But it depends, of
course, on your work.
So if you look at your work,
you have a certain percentage
of time that you
do your own stuff--
and then you can sit
here-- and a percentage
of time you collaborate.
And then you have
to be with a team,
with the project team, whatever
project team you're on.
And these might be different
from different happiness
clusters.
That's correct.
It's hard for me to
say now, will you
spend more time
collaborating or do
you sit more at your own
desk and do your own work.
That's one aspect of it.
The second aspect, which
is much more fundamental
is not the work,
but the work design.
And this is what your
happiness leader does together
with the CHO and
the executive part.
And this work
design is also new.
It's not the work
design you know.
You've got a work design.
OK, these are your goals.
Go.
But if that makes you happy
or not, no consideration.
Well, some leaders
are good, even today
in traditional
hierarchical structures.
And they know very
well what you can
and what you can't, what you're
good at and what you hate.
So they will design the work
accordingly, if they are good.
So where was the-- yeah.
AUDIENCE: So I can't
understand [INAUDIBLE]
for people sort of more or
less [INAUDIBLE] together.
DR. JOHANNES FREIESLEBEN:
Only what they think.
Not only what they--
to some extent, yes.
AUDIENCE: Do you think is
some risk of maybe [INAUDIBLE]
forcing that they
provide [INAUDIBLE]?
I guess on a product
level, you can
think about
[INAUDIBLE] countries
and sticking only
with [INAUDIBLE]
and what implications this
might have. [INAUDIBLE]
corporation where, at
the moment, if you're
on a team with people
who think differently,
your own way and thinking
are not reinforced.
But in this case, [INAUDIBLE].
DR. JOHANNES FREIESLEBEN:
Very good question.
The question was if there is
a high risk of groupthink,
that you foster groupthink
in those groups.
Well that risk exists.
That is true.
How do you counterbalance that?
As I said before,
the idea is not
that you find your
perfect clones
and put all your
clones into one group.
Then I think the risk would
be very high for groupthink.
You have to look for
the fundament that
needs to be the same, I'd
say, like the wavelength,
the chemistry between you.
But your abilities
and your talents
might be completely different.
And I think that minimizes also
the risk of serious groupthink
catastrophe in those
happiness clusters.
But I agree this is
a topic that needs
to be addressed, absolutely.
FEMALE SPEAKER: OK,
that is actually
all we have time for today.
So I would just like to give
a warm thanks to the professor
for coming in and talking to us.
And if you have
any more questions,
I'm sure he'll be available
for a few minutes afterwards.
DR. JOHANNES FREIESLEBEN: Sure.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Thanks very much.
DR. JOHANNES FREIESLEBEN:
Thank you for having me.